Michael's just in case you want to take
a shower during the podcast it's an
extra feature in order to make our
guests feel welcome but we'll keep it
clean we won't need a tough Michael
Pollan Wow welcome thank you Jason very
good to be here thanks for coming on I
gotta say I've been a fan for many many
years
and it's just an absolute privilege to
be here with you and I just salute you
for your work in the world
for your work Thanks oh that's how we
soften our guests so you've had quite a
year yeah I didn't expect to be spending
an entire year talking about
psychedelics all over the world that's
right um you know I had my expectations
for this book were pretty modest I mean
I didn't really didn't know that people
wanted to read a book about psychedelics
did you have an inclination though that
this was gonna resonate because I mean I
read your New Yorker article a few years
ago the trip treatment yeah and that
that really jolted me because I thought
wow okay so here is a a rigorous and
sober account of the ways in which
psychedelics can offer pathways to
transformation and healing without
becoming an inflated self-righteous
piece full of spiritual ego saying I
went to God just to see and I was
looking at me you know I mean I was just
like I was marveled at that I mean you
introduced some some key ideas so that
must've told ya I mean the response that
article was very heartening that's why I
got to write the book yeah and I was
able to show that to my editor and yeah
it's like yeah let's do something cuz
yeah and that that article was very much
a straight piece of science journalism
you know is all white coats yeah ya know
first person right hand cuz I don't know
that I could have gotten the New Yorker
to publish that many words sure I could
Alex if it weren't science journals sure
so I it did open the door to writing
about this but there's still there's
this the Shibboleth and book publishing
the drug books don't sell and and I had
you know I was known to most of my
readers as someone who writes about
nutrition
and food and agriculture and would they
come along so there was a plenty of
anxiety around it a beautiful anxiety
though because you know it also give you
immense credibility that you were not
necessarily a psycho not right ahead and
try kool aid I came at it from as an
outsider and I had the journalist
skepticism I had and then I had the
personal nervousness about the whole
thing I didn't I hadn't used
psychedelics in a serious way until I
was in my late 50s so I think that that
that made it an easier path for people
to to go along with me because I wasn't
most most books about psychedelics have
been written from inside the tent that's
right and inside baseball
yeah therefore people are already
convinced to their value who have
already had the experience or a lot of
experience so mine was kind of a primer
for people outside right and now do you
find that um people who have read how to
change your mind and have been inspired
by it how many of those people were
aware that in a previous book the botany
of desire you wrote a lot about cannabis
which is another healing psychoactive
plant now having a in a completely legal
framework in California in other states
you know being used for all kinds of
healing modalities and having an
economic boom and and yet very little
has been written about the the first
person's subjective effects of cannabis
outside of the strictly medical no I
don't like why would a high functioning
creative intellectual benefit from
cannabis like there's been very little
writing about what is it about cannabis
and yet in botany of desire
I felt you had put out there the most
eloquent account of cannabis
phenomenology I had come across and as
somebody who has enjoyed delicious
reveries on the back of cannabis I am
somebody that needs to tile experiences
in language like that's how I make sense
of my own thoughts my putting thing me -
I I can't think without writing the
exactly useless I can't think without
speaking so there you
but but you specifically had written so
eloquently about cannabis and so I would
have thought that already that that
prepared you for writing how to change
your mind in terms of the first person
account because well it was heated up
you teed it up in that I had such I had
such pleasure writing that chapter and
thinking that way and thinking about how
we change consciousness and why we
change God why is it adaptive to change
consciousness it would seem to be
maladaptive right from a strictly
Darwinian point of view you you're
putting yourself in jeopardy you're
vulnerable your discombobulation of the
lion could come get you and you wouldn't
you would think it was a that's a
tradition and that's right
and so I but your your theory was that
it led to mutations and thought yeah it
had a very important role and I think
this is true of psychedelics - I call it
a mutagen or what did I call it a meme
it's a mutagen for memes okay we have
mutagens for genes various environmental
influences radio solar radiation for
example that mutate genes lead to
mutations that in some cases end up
advant advantage Ingush right right the
same thing happens in cultural evolution
you have these kind of weird new takes
on things most of them are [ __ ] sure
nonsensical but every now and then one
of them comes come turns out to be
really valuable and it totally sends
evolution on a new course and so I mean
they so you could say that the entire
history of Western philosophy from the
time of Plato was mediated by his own
experiences when they would have their
Diaries it may be I mean it's amazing
how many people in Greek society
participated in these rites and it
appears we don't know for certain that
there was a psychedelic involved
possibly derived from our God which is
the fungi right yeah it's the fungi that
that is the basis of LSD and in fact
there's a there's some new research
coming out I was told about in the next
few months where they
and residues and some little pots and
grease and found some LSD like compounds
so we may well find that yeah that along
the way drug experience has affected
evolution cultural evolution yeah now
Terence Mckenna said it affected
biological evolution too sure the stoned
ape theory which I have you know I am
not convinced by it yeah I find it
although it is compelling it's
compelling but I think fanciful the
piece that's missing is how does this
enter the genome I get how it ends or
enters the cultural history well the
same way that trauma enters the genome
right I mean don't they say that you can
inherit trauma in the nervous system so
maybe the inverse is also true
epigenetics sure it's possible it's
possible I remember I remember reading
this this quote ones that said our cells
are a technology that turns experience
into biology and that was an epigenetic
piece and so if that stuff can
eventually if your experiences become
seeded in the organism essentially right
you become the sum of your experiences
or you become what you behold and
certainly what you behold during a
profound altered states of alter state
of consciousness can have all kinds of
repercussions for the rest of your life
and the decisions that you make and the
things that get passed down in culture
and so on well we've seen it with trauma
we've seen it with starvation there's a
certain there's certain phenomenons that
get carried for it but for a couple
generations I don't know that we've seen
them in permanent parts that you know
interesting but I think that the where
there is a lot of potential validity to
that is looking at things like religion
you know that the the very idea that
there is a beyond or an unseen world of
some kind
you're an afterlife where would you get
those ideas I mean dreams yeah to some
extent but it seems to me that
psychedelic experience could well be the
source of those ideas very much and and
also the fact that psychedelic like
experiences can emerge without the
ingestion of psychoactive agents in
certain situations I mean you fast for
40 days or a certain contemplative
practices it's not difficult to imagine
that so many of the
vision earring that took place in the
past that led to gospel like pieces of
writings was inspired by profoundly
altered modes of perception oh yeah
there are many ways to get there
psychedelics is there they're really a
shortcut yeah you know I I was recently
given a light therapy by it worked
yeah I was pretty amazing and I I lie
down and this this woman had this device
called a I don't remember the name of it
I was invented by some scientists in
Austria and it flashed light to a couple
different kinds of light yeah and I had
my eyes closed listening to music on
headphones and it was amazing how
quickly had put me in a what felt like a
hypnagogic state of consciousness which
is the state right before sleep when
you're getting these very brief snatches
of narrative and imagery that that are
very elusive and it's a very pleasant
state of things so you can't really grab
on to think yes it doesn't have as much
narrative coherence as psychedelics okay
but anyway yeah within you know seconds
and I had my eyes closed and I was
seeing these incredible patterns of
light that were very kaleidoscopic and
lots of color and then I asked her I
took you know I opened my eyes later I
said well what were you seeing when I
was seeing that and she was only seeing
white light and my mind had broken it up
into the different pieces of the
spectrum according to what logic I have
no idea sure so there are many ways to
get to these states of consciousness I
think they're really important in human
evolution in human history well and and
there's a reason that as a species we've
sought them yeah well and that that is
triggering my next thought here I read a
book a couple of years ago I can't
remember the name but I remember that
the basic the basic subject was the
biological advantage of being awestruck
hmm and essentially was saying that
these kinds of experiences that hint
subjectively at the felt encounter with
a beyond or with spaces pregnant with
cosmological existential meaning can
inform the behavior of the species to do
acts of self-sacrifice and altruism you
know and be guided by the North Star and
drape the cosmos with consciousness and
set sail in a black ocean before we had
to satellite communications and that and
that these divinations can be useful
fictions yeah that can then have a
biological advantage because they imbue
us with a felt experience that we matter
and that our lives matter and we're
willing to sacrifice services that's
right to something larger that's right
you know I mean Decker Keltner who's a
mutual friend of ours yes studies Oz a
psychologist at Berkeley and you know he
says that all is a pro-social emotion
because it shrinks the ego it encourages
the small self and and therefore more
openness and willingness to cooperate
with the group may may well be true and
that may be one of the things that does
another thing I think it does it's
important is essentially well deal with
boredom which is a existential problem
right most people for most of time and
we're less bored than people were
probably for most of history we've
invented so many ways to entertain
ourselves back in the to our dad word
they were either bored or scared yeah
bored or scared sure or working so I was
excited when I first discovered
csikszentmihalyi's beyond boredom and
anxiety because most humans are just
oscillating between the states and I
want to read to you one of your own
quotes from how to change your mind
which talks about why travel certain
kinds of drugs and beauty are celebrated
for their capacity to move us beyond
those oscillations between boredom and
anxiety there's so much of our default
well you know our default is to develop
some really slick algorithms to help us
get through experiences by essentially
approaching them as models of previous
experiences and like oh this is like
that so I'm gonna react like that right
saves energy it saves energy it's very
efficient I think if we had to reinvent
the wheel and deal with fresh experience
and a new way to deal with it every
single time it would be exhausting and
and we would not get a lot done that's
right so there's a there's a lot of
benefit to it most of these things are a
two-edged sword it's important to us
with all the tools you can use cook you
can use fire to cook your food or to
burn the village exams the alphabet for
poetry and for encoding knowledge or for
hate speech propaganda yeah I always say
this is in my lectures about technology
it's like everything's a double-edged
sword
certainly ecstatic technologies are -
yeah no I think that's absolutely true
so so that's another use boredom
distracting us from pain and misery very
very important things but I think a lot
of it is innovation
I really think you that the the species
or the the mind in in crisis needs to
break out of those algorithms and try
something new and psychedelics frees us
from habits of thought from the way we
did it last time we forget the way we
did it last time or you know it just
it's blown up and and that's that's
where the novelty enters the picture I
think their novelty generating machines
now most novelty is not necessarily good
I mean just as mutations are in your
nature don't usually work but every now
and then one works really well it'll
[ __ ] against the wall until something
sticks yeah so some mystic sandy and
psychedelics throw a lot of [ __ ] against
the law well so this is interesting
right because you know if we if we go
back then to what we're ultimately
saying we're saying that um altered
states of consciousness or occasional
encounters with different ways of being
in different ways of seeing are
cognitively useful potentially
cognitively beneficial emotionally
beneficial right so well healing - yeah
yeah healings in right so so so so much
of transform it so much transformation
can happen when we encounter an altered
state of consciousness and that and so
and these altered states of
consciousness can be can be
characterized by profound awe profound
existential cosmological wonder and we
know that on Wonder our healing and you
know our friend
stacker dr. Decherd oh he always
mispronounces name well I am hope I'm
pronouncing right he's never corrected
ya you know when I came across the
studies in awe I was blown away because
the description was very similar to the
way a mystical experience on
psychedelics is described so they
described aw as an experience of
consciousness in which your mental
models of the world are so stretched
right ah is stretches your mental models
of the world beyond their normal
boundaries or limitations which brings
to mind that line that once a mind is
stretched by a new idea never referred
to as original position right you're
transcending your cognitive kansas and
you're going to Oz so you know you're
Dorothy you're Alice down the rabbit
hole but that these experiences of
stretch your mental models of the world
force you into now accommodating this
new experience and that act of
accommodation is what changes you yeah
because now yeah the birth of a child
the Grand Canyon you know the first time
you saw the images of the Hubble Space
Telescope and that that act of
accommodation that act of literal
expansion of self it leaves all these
positive residual benefits yeah
increased well-being increased
compassion increased creativity so we
know for a fact that that the quaking
annihilate Inglourious written about the
obliteration of self caused by an
encounter of such profound beauty in
cosmological wonder makes you a nicer
better kind or more compassionate person
not always well I I argued this point
with Dekker all the time
there is another kind of awe there's the
other people are feeling at a trump
rally
there's the aural people felt at
Nuremberg rallies in crowds well it can
be many mobs that's true so I think
again double-edged sword we have to keep
that in mind very well put well there's
a kind of political ah or fistic awe
that's right that we shouldn't lose
track of I'll do I'm from Venezuela I
saw ah Chavez's followers following him
straight into oblivion I've seen how I
guess can be hijacked by by politics the
leaders and the the subordination of the
the self the ego to the greater good
doesn't leave a greater good right I can
leave the mob violence too so I think we
need to keep that in mind but that is
true well okay fair enough we need to
keep that in yeah nevertheless I think
yeah you're the larger point is true
sure there's a lot of positive benefits
that come out of this kind of experience
yeah and and psychedelics are in all
experience right it's it's a chemically
induced experience of all that's right
well that this is where this is what I
was going is in in this relationship
between if we know that that ah can be
cognitively beneficial and that the
responsible use of certain ecstatic
tools like psychedelics can I guess you
could say be democratize access to the
sacred potentially taking it out of
institutions like traditional religions
that we may be disillusioned with or
feel that they have been corrupted
because they have used ah
to lead us to hate the other or to judge
the other that out every individual can
see and have his own experience of awe
and wonder potentially because these
tools unmediated yeah by an institution
one media by institution but mediated by
a tool right the tool offers the portal
or the gateway right and so do you think
that then this that the Renaissance of
psychedelics or the legalization of
cannabis then has created a world where
we have increased David Lentz ins la
align a potential for increased
stewardship of internal life and
stewardship of altered states of
consciousness like experiences which
gives which which can give us more
regular access to these modes of mind
and meaning that seemed to be so healing
yeah I think so I mean I think it's a
tool that we're putting people in you
know we're mean it's still illegal we
have to remember not in the case of
cannabis but in the case of psychedelics
but it is making these kind of
experiences available to more people
it's still not I mean it's democratized
to an extent I mean it's it's striking
how white and affluent the psychedelic
community is I've read a lot and
and and so we have to keep that in mind
but it it is putting it it is
circumventing the institutions that
mediate certainly spiritual law and that
of course has been threatening to them
over the years right I mean we saw this
when the conquistadores got to to Mexico
and and people had these mushroom
ceremonies and they were having these
ecstatic experiences that the Spanish
watched and then realized when they
heard that the that the indigenous
peoples called their mushrooms at tio T
and not to coddle which meant flesh of
God which is of course exactly what the
Catholic Eucharist was eating the flesh
of the gods they were like no no no we
have that monopoly
you're not going to challenge that and
and we've seen this the Reformation was
all about people wanting unmediated
contact with the divine so so far there
hasn't been a backlash on that order but
stay tuned I imagine you read the Life
magazine article by Gordon wass on he
was the first Westerner that went and
took mushrooms with me you know yeah do
you know I never forget that line where
he described the experience he said he
spent the evening
uttering ejaculations of amazement it's
your kind of sentence totally like you
know it's so funny I've done videos
where I was talking about ejaculations
of amazement or extact you lations as i
was calling them and i got made fun of
so much but but it's so true okay so
this is the question now I spent a lot
of time trying to find the language or
just I guess enjoying putting words to
these reveries these easy these healing
reveries because III do not ascribe
subscribe to any traditional religion
but I would be lying if I said that I
don't have a religious life in the sense
that I choose to believe that you know
that that that life matters and that we
aren't insignificant and that agency and
freewill and our capacity to engender
creative things in the world is
meaningful you know right and so that's
that's a leap of faith that I'm
ultimately taking I mean we're also a
speck of dust suspended in a sunbeam
yeah it looks sake say something sacred
is basically
statement it has a lot of meaning nice
yes it's it's it's it's imbued with
meaning correct right and that's a
that's fundamentally a religious idea
exactly and and so you know when I try
to describe for people the phenomenology
or the subjective experience of an
altered state of consciousness that is
healing like people will say well why
like why is it healing like it's is it
like being drunk you know it it's like
well no it's not like being drunk it's
just different then and and you wrote
about this in the beginning of how to
change your mind you said that the and
I'm paraphrasing correct me if I if I
get it wrong but you said that the the
human brain like we have these the human
brain works like an artificial
intelligence system we take in data from
the present we compare it with data from
the past and we use that to make
inferences about the future so the brain
is a prediction machine and those
algorithms get set in stone by the time
we're adults and and so our default is a
kind of future tense with a low level
hum of anxiety right and then and then I
chuckled you were like the good news is
I'm seldom surprised but the bad yeah so
that's the default right that's 21st
century normal that's Jamie wheels like
fibrillating anxiousness you know and
accessor baited by social media and
attempting to multitask and not getting
enough sleep and the anxiety of not
having meaning in our lives because we
have dead-end jobs that we hate so we're
not living our passion or whatever it
may be the amount of people committing
suicide now being more than the amount
of people that die from armed conflict
and natural disasters combined the
epidemic of depression you know like all
this mental health stuff that's
happening it seems to be precisely
because people are there's that there's
a kind of like overactive future focused
anxious state you know the yeah hold
hard hard Harris and Trump up Murray the
default mode Network the ego is like
metastasized into an oppressive we're
all walking around like oppressing
ourselves essentially in effect
I mean basically we have overactive egos
right
and egos can be very punishing and you
know the the the algorithms get too
rigid and they they worked under some
circumstance but over time they're no
longer working the environments change
the needs have changed but we're stuck
in here ducking the source and and you
know we all have this experience of
having certain narratives we play over
and over we know now we're in the brain
that happens yeah why it happened that's
right but they're very hard to escape
and one of the things that really struck
me in my research about mental health
which is a big part of what the book is
about is that all these disorders of
mind including depression anxiety
obsession eating disorders are may all
be the same thing yeah more or less
which is to say being trapped in
destructive narratives right habits of
thought that no longer serve the
organism very well
yeah and then you can't move past them
you can't step outside of them you
cannot get the perspective you can't you
can't lift yourself far enough outside
of yourself to seize right that it is
just a narrative and it's and it's
inaccurate you know that narrative that
says you're can't get through the day
without a drink or a cigarette or that
you're unworthy of love you're stuck in
the loop and if this is very interesting
it reminds me of that article that I
shared with you by Chris let the beat
yeah about how psychedelics violate our
expectations about self and world so
we've been talking about we have these
algorithms that create these no because
the brain is prediction machine so these
algorithms of expectation can
metastasize into like a depressed person
always expects everything to be
depressing right and anxious and let it
become exactly because it's also that
feedback loop that you become what you
expect yeah and an anxious person always
expects everything to be angry and
you're stuck in these loops and you
can't get out of them without setting a
bad predictions essentially that's right
that you're stuck in and so what they
say in that article is and they were
talking about the epistemic value of
psychedelics whether or not the contents
of the experience were true empirically
like you met God or you saw the
afterlife that matters not the epistemic
value is that people who have an
experience that essentially violates
their expectations right is an
experience that is beyond mere
description because you can tell a
depressed person there's another way to
see the world if you just go stand over
there
no no literally I could put you on a
plane we could go to South Africa you
the elephant's and you could forget
about your problems like literally but
that's just knowledge by description
that doesn't get through they talk about
instead what psychedelics can provide is
an experience of knowledge by
acquaintance and the knowledge by
acquaintance is you pick the person up
and you put them somewhere else and now
the secret world yes its knowledge by
experience that's right and and that's
the thing that some scientists have
trouble getting their head around when
you're giving a patient a psychedelic
yes you're not giving a drug that's
right giving an experience that's right
and that and in the same way trauma can
be transformative in the negative right
that's right you can have a quantum
change from a positive experience
yes plus you also have this other kind
of experience which is of the new
perspective that's right you know the
many of the patients describe to me I
felt like the camera was pulled back
further than it's ever been I could see
myself beautiful and I realized how
stupid it was to smoke a cigarette right
and you know these were not profound
ideas in fact they're banal ideas yeah
but they acquired a certain Authority
because you were experiencing them a
freshly yeah that's a difference you
know felt it it was you know there's no
split between idea and feeling that's
wrong and that you become what you
behold it's McKenna's you well Roland
Griffiths from Johns Hopkins he'd coined
the term inverse PTSD which I think was
in the New York Eye that resonated a lot
because it's like well exactly you know
if trauma right is this undigested thing
right the body keeps the score and yeah
a profound experience that changed your
predictions right because now everything
is potentially more parikamma yeah and
and David Lanson talks about this - he
says expectations become negatively
prefigured so anxiety becomes a kind of
temporal dislocation the past trauma is
now becoming it has changed your lenses
of perception and it's over determining
the present so it's miss miss perceiving
what's happening now and conjuring up a
future that becomes identified with
death or doom or whatever it is your
fear and so it's a kind of it's this
temporal dislocation and so what is
needed is another experience equally
powerful a director at quake and I
elating glory becoming one with the Bach
music that's what happened to you
and that then that can literally allow
you to finally like digest and let go of
the trauma right to move beyond your
lenses of perception those lenses of
prediction right because we see with our
lenses and we see through our lenses but
we don't know we see the lenses
themselves that's right that's the other
thing that Chris leatherby had written
that these psychedelic experiences make
you aware of your own lenses so it's
like that soup that zooming out that
we're talking about allows you to see
the way in which you were seeing the
world that's right this for you know
that it was a way that's right yeah
that's 100% true yeah
so we know that this can be healing but
but back to the to the to the to finding
the words to describe these experiences
from the inside and back to the
beginning of how to change your mind so
we're talking about this future-focused
low-level anxiety bad news or good news
is I'm seldom surprised so I'm always
prepared for whatever's coming I'm not
gonna be so nobody's gonna surprise me
or sideline me but the bad news is I'm
seldom surprised there's never any
delight there's never any leg right joy
coming around the bend and then you say
and this is what really struck me
because this is where it gets into like
the sense of first sight unencumbered by
knowingness you said that one of the
things that commends travel which is
associated with novelty which I love
beauty an encounter with beautiful art
you know aesthetic arrests music and
then certain kinds of drugs where I
would put certain psychedelics and
cannabis at the right doses is that
these experiences block these words if I
remember correctly these experiences
block all signals forwards and backwards
so they're blocking the whole diction
and pass that's right so I'm not
comparing this with the past and I'm not
automatically like anticipating what's
around the bend if I got a deal with
what's in front of me yes for the first
time but truly truly deal with it right
and when you see it for what it is cuz
because when we're predicting where
we're saying this is enough like that
that I don't really have to attend to
the detail or in my life and so we're
not so we don't take it in that's right
we go right to the shorthand so there's
no joy there's no there's no childlike
joy that's right the pin there's and
seen bats of the adult mind right and so
and so again you go so by knocking these
signals forwards and backwards
you're finally dropped into the flow
another word I love off of the present
the flow of the present and then you go
the present that is literally wonder -
full wonder being the byproduct of that
unencumbered sense of first sight to
which the adult brain has closed itself
unencumbered sense of foresight is
exactly what we're talking about when
you can't compare this with what you've
seen before and therefore not engage
with it because those signals are
knocked off line because the short-term
memory disruption of psychedelics you
know is training your pool of sense
impressions as quickly as it fills it's
knocking you into these discrete present
moments that have no story attached to
them except for the delight of
encountering them and beholding them in
the moment it's the child's
consciousness that's right yeah that's
where it takes you and the child has at
least the young child has unencumbered
wishes to say a historical that's right
that's right and then it's so so then so
then this is where it gets exciting for
me mm-hmm
so you have childlike perception but
then you have adult sophistication and
language so there it's like then you're
blake then you're seeing the world in a
grain of sand from heaven in a wild
flower you're holding infinity in the
palm of your hand and eternity in an
hour
like I mean sometimes just to recite is
to become especially when you're in
those altered states of consciousness
and you're in the fully present moment
and you've knocked the signals forwards
and backwards off line and then you sort
of find the language and you recite the
language to describe what's happening
you can get into a really nourishing
feedback loop oh yeah characterized by
elation and reverie and gratitude and
grace and bliss and awe and that's what
we're talking about that is and you're
right about the adult mind bringing it
to bear I mean I think the best example
that I've read is all those Huxley in
doors of perception yes
title borrowed from Blake yes where he
on mescaline yes and this is apparently
a I've never tried mescaline but
apparently it's a property of mescaline
just spends so much time exact examining
you know the
folds of cloth in his pants which become
incredibly profound and then and then
lead him to the painting of cloth and
Renaissance you know artwork and that
ability to to take the Givens of our
lives the things we don't see anymore
and see meaning and wonder there is yeah
you have to you have to scrape away so
much to get there but the drugs scrape
it away a thousand percent and I also
think that well weird is what we're
talking about the regular encounters
with this space because I'm not
necessarily saying that we can live in
that space all the time because nobody
else after we have to fetch water and
chop wood because don't get me wrong a
part of me may be adolescent in me is
often like I want to feel this bliss all
the time because I'm so allergic to
banality and boredom and then another
one of your of your lines that stayed
with me what does banality and boredom
accept techniques the educated mind
deploys against experience so that it
can get through the day without being
continually exhaustingly astonished very
exactly so it's like it's like it's
exhausting to be in all the time you
gotta save it for sacred time you know
you got it you have Kairos but then you
also have to go Chronos and fetch water
and chop wood you know I mean like
there's a reason we don't stay in the
state our whole lives right it's very
good I mean you know Alison Gopnik who I
quote in the book the child psychologist
who really believes that psychedelic
experience is the closest version we
have to childhood consciousness the the
mind of the child is all about
exploration not exploitation and as you
move from explore to exploit that's
adults that's right and exploit is what
you need to do to chop the wood and get
things done and succeed and pass on your
genes and all this kind of stuff we have
to do as a species but there must be
this period also where we're simply
exploring and and one of the things
psychedelics do is it appears to and
this has been shown in other dimensions
of life reopen those windows that closed
on us as we get older there was a very
interesting experiment done with MDMA by
a neuroscientist named gold Dolan
Johns Hopkins not as part of the
psychedelic group there and there's a
period in the life of humans and mice
where they're maximally social it's the
teenage years for people and it's I
don't know exactly what it is it's day
12 for a mouse or whatever it is but
then it closes and they become very
solitary and she found when she gave
them both MDMA and I think LSD as well
that it reopened that window that
developmental window I had so I think
that it may be one of the one of the
things these tools do is allow us to
reopen windows that have been closed I
agree a hundred percent I have a
relationship with what you just said you
know exploration versus exploitation
because you might argue that that the
search is is exploration right Oh
exploring these altered states and
probing these altered states and
consuming the literature and feeding
your brain and just going out into the
unknown hurling yourself into the abyss
is a form of exploration but then you
could argue that all of my work this
conversation right now making the videos
bringing the camera along for the ride
to record the afterglow is then the
exploitation part it's like well how can
I capture this and share others yeah but
I think if you know if you have a
negotiation with yourself that is an
integrity I think you could live a life
that that is oriented around regular
access to I think we need a soul I'm and
then and then bring it back and then
fetch water and chop wood and write
attend with the unknown and then bring
it back and digestible form we're not
one thing and and we shouldn't strive to
be one that's right and we need these
different dimensions but yeah I mean I
just keep thinking that that we've
gotten so good at mechanized cognition
we've gotten so good at collaborating
and cooperating and creating systems and
instrumentalist relationships with one
another like your mobile driver and
you're the pilot of the plane I'm the
passenger of the plane and these
relationships that allow society to
function the I it relationship that
Martin Buber talks about yeah but then
we also need I now you know encounters
with the totality of another person
without an instrumentalist agenda
without a transactional agenda and with
ourselves encounter the infinity of
ourselves and labor we're applying to
ourselves I'm this kind of person that
does this kind of thing right and that's
not our whole selves and we we sell
ourselves short by I mean it's cliche
but it's so true it's like it's like
Dead Poets Society you
that speech by Robin Williams oh he's
like you know engineering science these
are noble pursuits necessary to sustain
life but poetry love romance this is
what we stay alive for and so if these
windows these encounters of these like
sublime approximations to whatever you
want to call the great beyond these
instances of poetic truth these
encounters with are so healing we just
need to get better and better I believe
at like reverse engineering the access
like I want to perfect the the portals
to aw you know like the set of best
practices just like you know my buddies
Steven Kotler and Jamie wheel and
stealing fire written about what they
call the altered states economy the ten
trillion dollars a year they're spent to
get out of our heads from entertainment
to move drugs other things and then
they're trying to figure out like these
advances that are happening now the four
forces of ecstasy psychology technology
neurobiology and pharmacology and how
our increasing understanding of those
four is giving us an increasing
demystifying sort of scientific approach
at being able to enter these states of
higher information access deconstruct
them reverse-engineer them and reproduce
them and like that could be the pathway
to healing the mental health crisis well
it could be and that that in a way is
what I'm most interested in because
there's you know there's a huge amount
of human suffering out there that I know
we could help relieve and and that's why
I'm so excited about this research going
on and the fact that these drugs are
moving toward approval both MDMA for
trauma and psilocybin for depression and
yeah the anxiety of the dying and and a
whole bunch of other indications and but
the other thing to keep in mind is we're
all on a spectrum with the mentally ill
right I mean it's not oh yeah no no I
think we're doing we're all suffering
from micro PTSD bruh you know trauma is
remarkably common depression is common
anxieties Department I mean they're
different degrees of it and and that's
one of the reasons I think that this
term I use in the book the betterment of
well people is something we also need to
keep in mind well this is very important
we have to but we have to go beyond
brain or consciousness hacking there
there is also a desire to be very
instrumental about this
turn it into another business another
edge I mean mitre dosing is about
improving productivity at work you know
oh the irony yeah and you know so I can
easily see this going down that path and
sure well that's like that's what's
savvy sometimes about capitalism is that
they'll take like genuine legitimate
attempts to break out of the indentured
servitude a broken system and yes I'll
sell you the tie-dye shirt I'll sell you
$90 yoga pants transcendence yeah no I
mean capitalism can we've learned can
co-op just about anything and I'm sure
it'll figure out a way to co-op
psychedelics it makes me it makes me
laugh so much I want to read you this
quote because when one of my things is
I'm always you know one of my favorite
lines by Isaiah Berlin is to understand
is to perceive patterns and with
language I'm always making connections
between things so I just I just read you
that um that quote by you or you talk
about them sort of the desire to escape
banality but also the reality that
banality is a energy saver yeah so so
you're one there's a lot of profundity
in what we consider banal that the the
Hallmark card which makes us want to
throw up nevertheless has a kernel of
emotional truth in it 100% but if we but
we also can't spend our whole time
marveling at the Hallmark card cuz I'm
not gonna get anything but I wouldn't
get out of the drug so so yeah exactly
so your words were what is a sense of
the banality of something if not a
defense of a defense against the
overwhelming power of that thing
experienced freshly banality depends on
memory as do irony and abstraction and
boredom three other defenses the
educated mind deploys against experience
so that it can get through the day
without being continually exhaustingly
astonish those are your words then I
stumble or I had ever used to
psychedelic by the way had you tried
cannabis we have yes okay and then
Martha Nussbaum
writes something similar because I was
trying to get into okay
yes banality and pain but at this I'm
not sure but I'm gonna read you the
quote because I was trying to get into
the defining characteristics of an a
like or a state of wonder like what it
feels like how to describe it from the
inside
and and I was like yeah okay banality
and boredom are ways that we shield
against being overwhelmed all the time
but when we are overwhelmed we find
ourselves like feeling we feel like our
eyes are opening for the first time and
so she says the characteristics of these
experiences of these jolting and
Awakening experiences are surprise vivid
particularities and extreme qualitative
intensity and she says these are all
characteristics that are systematically
concealed by the workings of habit which
is the primary form of self-deception
and self concealment when I said the
body but I wonder what it was from one
of those beautiful articles written by
brain picker mm-hmm and she was quoting
Martha Nussbaum but basically the ideas
are primal habit have it as the enemy
here correct correct because our primary
aim she says is to comfort ourselves to
a swash pain and to cover our wounds and
so that's the whole thing we hide behind
our habits you know then but then but
then we become miserable inside those
same habits that we hide behind it's
like you have to be able to be a self
aware enough to know what habits are
useful and advantageous and which habits
are providing a form of hiding from
yourself and where something that seems
very adaptive suddenly lapses into being
incredibly destructive and maladaptive
that's right but habit is I mean habits
are useful they're very efficient they
get us through the day yeah they help us
navigate routine events but they also
dull us to experience and anything that
breaks habits that's why I think travel
is so important - yes you land in a
foreign country and all your I mean it's
changing now because you can now you can
get an uber just like the way you don't
know them but it used to be yeah
everything was different how does this
work that's how do you get a cab
how do you navigate the city you know
how do you ask for X and and it's
exhausting but it's incredibly
stimulating - because you're you're
having to learn your hat you have to go
back into that Explorer phase that's
right not and you you're not ready
to exploit because you don't have enough
information that's right that's right
beautiful so let me ask you something
the entropic brain Theory robbing card
Hart Harris neuroscientists from
Imperial College of London I believe
your friend hmm
brilliant guy so this is a very
interesting theory and you touched on
this before it basically says that most
of the mental health pathologies that
we've like labeled into their own
subcategory like this person's depressed
or this person is anxious Mircea yeah
that it turns out that all of these seem
to be characterized by the same thing
happening in the brain which is the
default mode network which is the seat
of the autobiographical mind as of this
week has metastasized and become
overactive so this is this is where the
patterns have become imprisoning yeah
right and that the usefulness of these
psychedelic experiences whether they're
you know if by taking a psychedelic or
it's simply an extreme experience that
you have or meditation shake shake the
snow globe yeah right right but here
okay so what I'm curious about is that
okay so this this works for the
pathologies of a brain that has become
too ordered right which is depression
anxiety OCD of these things yeah too
much too much order too much garden too
much rigidity which or jitan mental
illness is formed around rigid habits of
thought okay but that they don't work
for illness and mental illnesses on the
other spectrum of a brain that's too
disordered right because the psycho
personality in character so this is
interesting to me because isn't it
possible that somebody with extreme
anxiety could it become psychotic
I mean it's so it's like couldn't they
like be so ordered that it eventually
the thing gets scrambled and they become
completely disorder is a good question I
don't know the answer to that because
there has been enough conversation yeah
that specific yeah you know like people
who are bipolar can go from depression
which you would be like psychedelics
could help to manic or stanza phrenic
like where you're like actually Skype
psychedelics are not going to that
and in fact with Bipolar they don't use
psychedelics they disqualify people they
cannot participate in the study so if
they're depressed because of their
bipolarism they don't screen for it they
can prove they have a way to screen for
people you present us depressed but you
can ask a few questions and determine
whether they have manic phases even got
they're widely dispersed
what about hypomania I don't know that's
it because that's another interesting
one that I've always wondered about
because it's again these things exist on
a spectrum right there's the wonderful
book the hypomanic edge which says that
sort of mild form of mania with high
executive function is actually
attributed to high success sure whether
it's like Steve Jobs or all these
leaders that if there were you analyzed
them way did they connect the dots and
their pattern recognition capacities and
the spaces of mind they go are almost
manic but not quite and with as a high
executive function so they can kind of
steer the fire hose right but the fire
hose is coming now it's not steering
them right and I wonder then you know
Steve Jobs took LSD and said it was one
of the greatest experience of his life
and he was certainly like potentially
hypomanic not fully manic so it's a you
know I'm interested in this because that
stuff starts getting used more and more
in the psychotherapeutic context you
know people exist in spectrums so it's
like you know you might be like well
they're not manic but they exhibit
traits of hypomania should they still
take should they take it or not and I
think that's it's it's one of the things
that remains to be really learned is who
should and who shouldn't take these
drugs I mean it's important to stress
there are risks yeah and people do have
the occasional psychotic break on on
psychedelic drugs whether they were
destined to have that break or not is
really an open question many people who
are kind of priests gets a phrenic ya
feel weird and they start
self-medicating and they take lots of
POD and they take lots of alcohol and
they might take psychedelics and yeah
any of that can kick them over yeah so
we should be you know hesitant to say we
understand all this because we don't
well the entropic brain theory is a very
persuasive theoretical construct yet
puts a whole set of mental disorders at
one end and suggests that the
way that psychedelics introduces noise
into that system or heat into that
system
chaos really into that system is exactly
what it needs to loosen it up and that
there's a point of criticality between
being too rigid and too disordered Flum
balanced okay it's an order and and and
so maybe psychedelics can move us on
that spectrum knowing that when we need
to be moved so that's I find that a very
persuasive theory but it's just a
theoretical construct yeah and then I
also think that we need to bring into
unto the table at the importance of
interpretive frameworks as well it's
like you know the mystic and the Mad Men
are swimming in the same waters yeah but
the mystic is surfing and the madman is
drowning go to the hole Joseph Campbell
like mythological interpretation of this
you know he says that the schizophrenic
is simply in an altered state of
consciousness and he hasn't like been
you know the only way out is through he
hasn't been like pulled out in a way
that can heal them and indigenous
quarters in a society that doesn't in
indigenous cultures you know they might
make that person the shaman that's what
I think that is very interesting space
as well ya know I mean look there's a
lot we don't understand about mental
illness yeah and and and as a result our
tools for treating it are really shitty
I mean we really have lousy drugs so so
here's a thought and I'm curious to hear
to your reflections on it um Onis Becker
wrote a book called denial of death
highly recommend it changed my life
Pulitzer Prize winning book there's a
line in there and he might be citing
auto rank or some of these other guys
but he was basically saying that the
totality of the human condition you know
with our defense mechanisms dissolved is
is intolerable mortal beings finite
beings who can contemplate the infinite
housed in heart pumping breath gasping
decaying bodies and that the full
awareness of that and the only response
to that he says is full and open
psychosis and that schizophrenic sort of
denial
right right right well denial through
defense sophisticated elaborate defense
mechanisms and hero systems and culture
right and it schizophrenic czar
suffering from the true
was one line that really resonated you
know because they are unable to form the
defense's correct the character
structures you know he uses lines like
character is a vital lie a necessary
fiction you know the idea of a
personality and a culture that is
meaningful and you know you've all her
Ahri's notion of the useful fictions in
ret and they become true because they
govern our actions in the world and if
enough people believes in them and they
lead to real action that an acts really
changed their sense of reality yeah we
live in a consents in relive in a real
virtuality right the reality of the
virtual but so essentially Ernest Becker
says that you know ultimately we're all
traumatized because of the explicit
awareness Sheldon Solomon who is a
Becker scholar says the explicit
awareness that you're a breathing piece
of defecating meat destined to die and
ultimately no more significant than the
lizard or a potato I mean it's like whoa
right human beings are in quite the
predicament we have the mental capacity
to ponder these oh we're gonna die yeah
we can ponder the infinite ponder the
infinite seemingly capable of anything
yet we're housed in heart pumping breath
gasping decaying body so we're gods and
worms at the same time and that that is
at the root of our disquiet that is the
worm at the core that is the thing that
wakes us up at 2:00 a.m. with our heart
palpitating that is the hypochondriasis
that is the anxiety like yeah the brain
has become too ordered yeah the entropic
brain theory but the root of that is the
Armant ation right our consciousness
simply is unable to cope with the
reality of our condition and so to that
extent we're all [ __ ] unless we have
interpretive frameworks that can be
self-serving enough to cope you know
what's your kool-aid you know I wonder
your thoughts on that like what
reflection do you have about well I'd
wonder how becquer would feel about
psychedelic therapy as something that
essentially blows up all those defenses
and causes people to confront that and
really dwell on death I mean one of the
things that really strikes me I think
one of the most important things about
what's going on with psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy right now is that
it opens up a new conversation about
death that our society badly needs to
have
I interviewed for that piece the trip
treatment that you alluded to it in The
New Yorker about a dozen people who were
had cancer diagnosis some of them
terminal some not who had were given the
drug because of their what the doctors
call their existential distress it's
exactly what he's talking about right
I'm in the process which people feel
more when they have it diagonally it is
always essential anxiety since I was 15
but there's an doesn't have end-of-life
anxiety you know right but it gets
really acute at a certain point and and
when I first heard that it was like hey
I wouldn't want to go there that's not
what I want to be I wouldn't want to be
taking away my defense is when I'm
dealing with this heart this incredibly
hard problem that seems to me anti
Becker and nevertheless they had these
amazingly positive experiences in many
cases they underwent a death a kind of a
death rehearsal it was a their ego
dissolved and and yet they survived this
dissolution of ego and came out of it
feeling incredibly hopeful is the wrong
word I mean but that they had the sense
that something would persist that that
there was a that there was a great plane
of consciousness or love that they would
enter into and it sounds like they were
given dreams of immortality but it
wasn't quite that because sometimes the
dream was incredibly naturalistic so for
example there's this one woman who had
cancer ovarian cancer I think and she
she went into the soil and she was
traveling through the soil and she hit
against a wall and she realized it was
the wall of a crematorium and that was
her death and she was gonna that's where
that was her fate but but her body was
somehow disassembled under the ground
and her her molecules were taken up by
the plants and that felt great that's
what should happen it just seemed
perfectly natural to her now that of
course is a very naturalistic
description of what happens after you
die your body breaks down and your
molecules are taken up by the plants
yeah but she she could take a pleasure
in that in the way most of us can't
because she had redefined her sense of
self well that's exactly what
and that's the key and there's that
quote of mine which you probably know by
heart but I don't you seem to remember
everything you read I'm very impressed
by Bertrand Russell hmm and he was asked
when he was quite old he lived to be
quite old what
what's the secret how do you how do you
overcome your fear of death and he said
the key to overcoming identify when one
more things exciting band your sense of
what your self is it's not just this bag
of bones it's your it's your community
it's your kin it's your it could be your
nation it could be all of nature and the
more you can expand that sense of self I
mean Thoreau did that very well yeah
yeah all the Romantic poets the less
troublesome the death of your body can
be so we're also what is the we well so
we're ultimately talking then about the
story that you tell yourself about
yourself yeah fundamentally our capacity
to have an interpretive framework to
craft a narrative that makes life not
just bearable but wonderful that it's
all about the interpretive frameworks
and the interpretive framework
specifically about self expansion what
we're talking about the astronaut
overview effect yeah yeah astronauts go
into orbit and so what is that that's an
ontological awakening and absence or so
forceful reckoning well they're looking
at the plant I mean it's like it's got
to be something to be outside of the
planet and then see that that marble
floating in an infinite cosmic ash of
nothing is everything we are and
everything we've thought and every you
know it's it's it's you know Carl
Sagan's pale blue dot yeah and that they
seem to have this experience that sounds
a lot like a mystical experience in that
it enlarges the self or rich Doyle says
you tune in from the broadcast of the
ego to the broadcast of the whole mm-hmm
there's another great line because I
love lines this this got Tim duty wrote
an article about psychedelics and he
said that these experiences they
recontextualize the self into a
marvelous conduit in a timeless whole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebulae and back again
and so it's like when you have that
shift in self perception self-expansion
no doubt
to lose your fear of death the only
bummer is that when you actually die you
can't ruminate over how deliciously
beautiful that language that's the
problem I have with ultimate death
because I'm not yet convinced in in in
in cognition surpassing the death of the
brain and I love cognition so much but
that's kind of where I'm at with that
conundrum because I I see the poetry in
that Tim Duty line of how those moments
of expression and they have dissipated
my anxiety and made me feel that I am
part of something larger than myself but
then I hear about you know a person I
know who got cancer and then it's like
existential bummer all over again
yep well so we're at the same boat on
you know I mean Mike's I mean one of the
things that really struck me about my
experiences on psychedelics which I had
fairly later in life yeah you did a lot
of people was that there they do in a
funny way reconcile you to death in a
way that I didn't expect I mean I had I
had one of the most ecstatic experience
I had was death obsessed I mean I was
there were bones and and and my dead
grandfather came back to me and I and he
looked just like me and yet something
about it meant it all just seemed just
right and and then I merged with this
very sad piece of music by Bach cello
did you cry sweet yeah and it was so sad
and so beautiful at the same time and it
was and I this was after I had had an
experience of ego dissolution and then
this merging that follow sure and and I
think that's what the people the the
cancer patients were feeling something
very similar thank you a few reveries
more intoxicating than aesthetic
reveries I remember watching you know
the musical lemmas yeah they had a 25th
anniversary concert of it in London that
I that I watched
the massive stage like five choirs
behind the actors and their singing like
the last song the crescendo song like
one day more and they're all singing it
together and the audience's cry and
you're just like okay that you know that
is heaven Albert and you're doing it
together you could do like time dilation
and lose yourself in the climax of a
song and right it's like Jamie wheel
talks about the trifecta
it's tasses catharsis and communitas so
first the ecstasy the losing the sense
of self and tuning into the larger hole
then catharsis is the moment of finally
like surrendering and having the the
grief you know the fully letting go and
realization and communion and then
finally the sense of community and
merger with everybody else and and I
think that merging is really important
it's funny yeah I love those feelings so
much and it's like I still feel like the
vessel for those experiences is my
embodiment right and so that's why I'm
just like what the last as much as
possible because I'm and I'm a bliss
junkie ultimately yeah just like I live
for aesthetic arrest and it sounds from
some of the things you've written that
you can really do - yeah brother well
what can I say it's been such a pleasure
we've been chatting for an hour I could
talk to you forever but I want to
respect your time I want to say thank
you no thank you Jason really enjoy
inspiration and and yeah I'm glad to
have connected into have met you
thanks so much Michael Pollan anything
you want to point the audience to at the
moment uh your wonderful books I don't
think so yeah I mean you might point
people to the book we talked about
botany a desire which many fewer people
know about but a star is where I began
examining these questions and and was
really struck by the fact I mean I came
at all this work by my actually my
fascination with plants yeah
and how we are in this very rich
symbiotic co-evolutionary relationship
you know change us and we change them
that's right and we use them from great
many things but one of them is to change
consciousness and that desire is the one
that has obsessed me for quite a long
time I wanna I want to maybe end with
this one beautiful quote and I believe
it's from David lensing yeah and and so
you should tell people who he is
yes
totally David Lentz and teaches
comparative literature he wrote a book
called mass Amherst new and he wrote a
book called on drugs which is about the
phenomenon phenomenology of drug use
which we both agree is like the best
book written on drugs ever yeah and and
you know we've been talking about aw and
altered states of consciousness and
their characteristics that they seem to
take you out of time they take you from
Chronos or mechanized cognition to
Kairos to poetic time you know I often
use the analogy of like watching a film
so from the outside total running time
one hour and 20 minutes but from the
inside you could have a profound life
experience that occurs outside of time
and both are true you know like I had a
real experience that was outside of time
that's true but it also was only a
two-hour running time right there's that
Ursula Le Guin line where she says um
science describes accurately from the
outside so that's Chronos yeah poetry
describes accurately from the inside so
that's Kairos science explicate but
poetry implicates that's nice that's so
beautiful so then I'll leave you with
this one
what is metamorphosed in repeated
drug-taking or any kind of altered state
of consciousness is time
that's what's metamorphosed what
Einstein did for physics and Nietzsche
did for philosophy is recapitulated in
every drug affected mind drug
consciousness in the 20th century has
reflected and even mimicked changes in
the way physics and philosophy have
reinterpreted the universe once a
subject is accustomed to constructing
consciousness according to this
cognitive quantum mechanics the return
to a Newtonian universe is difficult to
achieve such a reversion it seems to the
user would require a renunciation of joy
and play of insight and vision and of
privileged knowledge and perception it
would entail a return to mechanized
cognition that's beautiful yeah David
Lansing
thank you michael paalan you're one of
my heroes thank you Jason great pleasure
Cheers
[Music]